[Musik]
Russlands brutaler Krieg hat die Welt
erschüttert warum stehen Länder wie
China an Putins Seite
china steht in erster Linie auf Chinas
Seite das Land ist ein egoistischer
Riese
solange Chinas Wirtschaft brummt
herrscht Pragmatismus
Politik hat mit uns nichts zu tun wir
haben gute Beziehungen mit Russland und
der Ukraine
Südafrika lässt gemeinsam mit Russland
die Muskeln spielen ein Militärmanöver
mit dem historischen Partner was denken
die Menschen über Russland unter Putin
er ist charismatisch er ist ein
männlicher Mann
wir betrachten die Russen immer noch als
die die uns geholfen haben im Kampf
gegen die Apartheid
Brasiliens Bauern brauchen Russlands
Dünger mit ihrer Ernte ernähren sie die
Welt Südamerikas wirtschaftsriese will
sich nicht auf eine Seite schlagen
es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund und sind
ein Krieg einzumischen der nicht der
unsere ist es gibt ein Konsens auf der
linken und auf der rechten
eine Auszeit vom Krieg an Thailands
Stränden
wir wissen nicht wie die Menschen auf
uns reagieren es könnte Probleme geben
Thailand empfängt russische Touristen
mit offenen Armen
wir können uns nicht erlauben den Russen
zu sagen ihr dürft nicht kommen
der Krieg hat die Welt verändert wer
sind Putins Treue Partner
[Musik]
wie steht China zu Russland
was sagt die Staatsführung und was macht
sie
[Musik]
nicht mal die offizielle Linie ist
einfach zu beschreiben
noch weniger wie die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zu ihren Nachbarn stehen
halten die Chinesen zu Russland
und wenn ja warum
dieses Viertel haben wir uns als
Startpunkt für unsere Recherche
ausgesucht
wir sind im Jahr bei luviertel im Osten
Pekings hier finden wir erste russische
Spuren
die Läden in diesem Einkaufszentrum sind
voll mit russischen Schriftzeichen
das Viertel ist bekannt für seine
pelzläden wichtiges groß und
Einzelhandelszentrum mit Verbindungen
nach Russland
viele Stockwerke in diesem riesigen
Gebäude sind Gespenste schwer
weit oben treffen wir Anja und fragen
warum hier alles auf Russisch steht
unsere Kunden sind aus
russischsprachigen Ländern sie müssen ja
verstehen was wir verkaufen sonst würden
es nur Chinesen verstehen aber wir
machen Außenhandel nicht für Chinesen
Anja erklärt uns Ihr Geschäft sie ist
zwischenhändlerin seit zehn Jahren
verkauft sie vor allem Schuhe
vor allem nach Russland seit der
Pandemie vor allem über die
Messenger-App wechat ich poste jeden Tag
Bilder die Kunden schauen sich das an
und schicken mir die Bilder von den
Modellen zurück die sie haben möchten
der Chat ist auf Russisch ob Anja
russisch spricht
klar schon lange die 40-Jährige kommt
aus Zoe von Hill im Nordosten Chinas
direkt an der russischen Grenze
sie haben großen Bedarf an unseren waren
deswegen ist die Beziehung gut
jetzt wo es Krieg gibt zwischen Russland
und der Ukraine fragen sie uns auf
welcher Seite wir stehen aber wir
verstehen uns mit beiden Ländern die
Leute sind gutherzig Politik hat mit uns
nichts zu tun wir haben gute Beziehungen
mit beiden
bloß nicht über Politik sprechen das
hören wir in Interviews häufig etwas
gegen die offizielle Linie der
Staatsführung zu sagen ist gefährlich
und weil die oft nicht ganz klar ist ist
es sicherer gar nichts Politisches zu
sagen
Anja schickt uns ins Untergeschoss da
würden wir sehen wie gut die Beziehungen
zu beiden Ländern sind
[Musik]
ich bin überrascht so sehen also die
Orte aus wo die Päckchen herkommen die
seit ich in China lebe so schnell auch
zu meiner Haustür gebracht werden und
nicht nur nach China in die ganze Welt
hier wird verpackt gewogen und
beschriftet die Bestellungen die oben
per Handy reinkam
seit zehn Jahren arbeitet dieser Mann
hier die meisten Pakete gehen nach
Russland daran habe der Krieg nichts
geändert was drin ist
vor allem Klamotten und wie lange
brauchen die
gut zehn Tage
ein paar Garagen weiter erzählen sie uns
das Russlands Angriffskrieg ihr Geschäft
hart getroffen hat
sie haben Krieg wer hat denn da noch
Lust Sachen zu bestellen
was hier an Paketen verschickt wird sei
nichts im Vergleich zu den großen
Hafenstädten sagt Anja noch sie rät uns
nach Nienburg im Osten Chinas zu fahren
zu einem der größten Häfen der Welt
wie steht es um das Verhältnis von China
zu Russland die einen sagen der Krieg
das hat mit mir und meinem Geschäft
nichts zu tun die anderen erzählen dass
wegen des Kriegs weniger bestellt wird
ein sehr pragmatischer Umgang mit Fragen
von Krieg und Frieden typisch für viele
Chinesinnen und Chinesen
auf tiktok stoßen wir noch auf eine
russisch chinesisches Pärchen
Alltagsgeschichten
wir schreiben Ihnen eine Nachricht und
sind erstaunt wie schnell sie antworten
und dass sie bereit sind uns zu treffen
Rio de Janeiro wie ist die meisten
kennen dürften Kilometer lange Strände
vor spektakulärer Natur doch jenseits
der postkartenkulisse ist das Leben der
Menschen hier geprägt von harter Arbeit
viele kämpfen täglich und Überleben der
Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine
scheint da unendlich weit weg oder wir
möchten wissen inwieweit der Krieg in
der Ukraine hier in Brasilien ein Thema
ist
können wir Ihnen eine Frage fürs
deutsche Fernsehen Stellen haben sie
ganz kurz Zeit es dauert nur eine Minute
was wissen Sie über den Krieg zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine
ich weiß gar nichts darüber ich arbeite
ich sehe nicht mal fern ich muss um 6
Uhr morgens von zu Hause los
ich weiß nichts ich habe davon in
letzter Zeit nichts in den Nachrichten
gesehen
wie sollte die brasilianische Regierung
reagieren
ich finde Brasilien sollte sich da nicht
einmischen die sollen das unter sich
ausmachen ich glaube wenn Brasilien sich
einmischt wird uns das Schaden
das ist nicht unser krieg ich denke wir
sollten da keine Leute hinschicken
die spontane Straßenumfrage ist zwar
nicht repräsentativ aber sie bestätigt
unseren persönlichen Eindruck aus den
letzten Monaten die Menschen hier wissen
wenig über den Krieg er ist weit weg
auch die Regierung hat sich bisher nicht
klar gegen den russischen Aggressor
positioniert will neutral bleiben die
eigenen Probleme sind viel näher
Wirtschaftskrise Arbeitslosigkeit Hunger
hatte Krieg irgendwelche Auswirkungen
auf sie direkt für mich nicht aber alle
sind irgendwie betroffen die Welt
verliert Leben gehen verloren und es
sind traurige Zeiten
hatte der Krieg Auswirkungen auf ihr
Leben hier wenn ich egoistisch denke
würde ich sagen nein gar nicht wenn ich
als Mensch denke natürlich denn Menschen
werden getötet für gar nichts
die Menschen fühlen zwar mit den
Ukrainern doch konkrete Auswirkungen des
Krieges auf ihren Alltags sehen sie
nicht dabei gibt es sie und wir müssen
gar nicht lange nach ihnen suchen wir
besuchen einen Kindergarten am Stadtrand
von Ried
guten Morgen da sind wir vom deutschen
Fernsehen wie geht es Ihnen
alles bestens herzlich willkommen
wir sind hier weil wir wissen wollen wie
sich der Krieg auf die Ernährung von
Kindern auswirkt immer mehr sind auf das
Essen in Schulen und Kindergärten
angewiesen weil es zu Hause nicht genug
gibt nicht ohne Grund steht die
Speisekarte direkt am Eingang des
Kindergartens
gibt es Kinder die zu Hause hungern
ja es gibt viele Kinder die hierher
kommen und zu Hause kein richtiges Essen
haben sie kommen dann hier zu uns in den
Kindergarten unsere Ernährung ist
ausgewogen und darauf ausgerichtet diese
Kinder zu versorgen
das beizubehalten wird immer schwieriger
weil die Preise für Essen und Energie
steigen hier im Kindergarten schaffen
sie es noch aber zu Hause müssen viele
Familien Abstriche machen
[Musik]
zu Hause ersetzen wir bestimmte
Lebensmittel durch andere die billiger
sind als Folge des Krieges hat sich
unsere Ernährung insgesamt
verschlechtert unsere Kaufkraft ist
stark gesunken weil die Preise so sehr
gestiegen sind und noch weiter steigen
auf geht's in die Küche
hier hat Andrea das Sagen jeden Tag
bereitet sie das Essen zu Frühstück
Mittagessen Abendessen
den Speiseplan Stellen
Ernährungswissenschaftlerin zusammen
damit die Kinder keinen Mangel leiden
gefällt Ihnen die Arbeit hier
ja sehr es ist toll die Freude der
Kinder zu sehen wenn sie etwas zu essen
bekommen
aber die Preise sind ziemlich gestiegen
oder ja sie sind sehr stark angestiegen
ist es dadurch schwieriger geworden ja
ziemlich aber wir finden immer einen Weg
den Kindern schmeckt es nicht nur sie
erhalten auch eine Bandbreite an
Nährstoffen und Abwechslung die ihnen
viele Eltern nicht mehr bieten können
Karotten mag ich nicht so gerne aber mir
schmecken Kartoffeln
[Musik]
viele grundnahrungsmittel sind teurer
geworden weil auch die brasilianische
Agrarindustrie unter den steigenden
Preisen für Energie und Dünger leidet
gleichzeitig exportiert Brasilien weiter
in die ganze Welt für Direktorin Fatima
sollte die Regierung Lebensmittel
subventionieren
[Musik]
sie könnten es uns einfacher machen wir
sind doch ein Land das viele
Lebensmittel herstellt aber wir schicken
all das ins Ausland zuerst sollten wir
uns im eigenen Land ernähren können und
das was übrig bleibt könnte dann
exportiert werden wie alt dies
zusammenhängt und warum sich Brasiliens
mächtige Agrarindustrie aus dem Krieg
heraushalten will werden wir auf unserer
Reise ins Landesinnere erfahren
Kapstadt Traumziel am südlichsten Zipfel
Afrikas Millionen von Besuchern genießen
jedes Jahr die Ausblicke vom Tafelberg
das Zusammentreffen von Atlantik und
indischem Ozean das coole Cap Leben auch
Russen
hier an der berühmten Waterfront schoben
sie sich um die Jahreswende die Marina
entlang er zählt mir Reiseführerin
Mikaela nordi unerzogen sagt sie seien
sie gewesen wir schippern vorbei an
Luxusyachten Geld scheint es mir
reichlich zu geben und auch die junge
Anna Novikova der wir zufällig begegnen
scheint daran keinen Mangel zu haben
ich bin hierher zum Urlaub machen
gekommen und um meine Freunde zu
besuchen ich habe mich sofort in
Kapstadt verliebt es gibt tolle Natur
den Ozean die Berge hier kannst du alles
finden
seit sechs Monaten lebt die 25-Jährige
hier ihre Eltern entfernt überweisen
ohne Probleme Geld nach Kapstadt ob der
Krieg ihr Leben schwerer mache frage ich
nein
für mich nicht für andere Menschen
vielleicht tun
der Krieg ist fast 15.000 Kilometer
entfernt vom unbeschwerten Leben in
Kapstadt
und doch hat er auch hier Auswirkungen
die Russen sind da auch auf dem
Immobilienmarkt wie so viele Investoren
aus aller Welt liegen sie ihr Geld in
Häusern und Apartments an wir sind
verabredet mit Paul Turner der Makler
beschäftigt 35 Mitarbeitende und ist
vornehmlich im Luxussegment unterwegs
wir verkaufen Anwesen von 10 bis 50
Millionen Rand also von einer halben bis
zu zweieinhalb Millionen Euro
ich zeige Ihnen zwei Häuser das eine für
1,3 Millionen das andere ist in hardbase
für 500 bis 600.000 Euro
beim Thema Russen wird turner-wort-tag
die konkurrenzo sagt der habe deutlich
mehr russische Kunden doch die will erst
gar nicht mit uns reden
Camps Bay gehört zu den exklusivsten
Vierteln Kapstadts einen fantastischen
Blick Pool und sechs Schlafzimmer gibt
es für 1,3 Millionen Euro seit Beginn
des Krieges haben die Preise deutlich
angezogen
seit Februar März letzten Jahres kommen
auf einmal mehr internationale Käufer
vor allem aus Deutschland
das ist eine Möglichkeit in der
südlichen Hemisphäre zu investieren
weltweit entfernt von dem was in Europa
passiert
[Musik]
wird um hier zu leben und ein Haus zu
haben
Südafrika auch bekannt für Korruption
und Kriminalität nun ein sicherer Hafen
stellt sich dann doch die Frage ob die
südafrikanische pro russland-politik
Investoren abschreckt
ing das ist eine interessante Frage das
hatte ich tatsächlich erwartet aber es
ist nicht passiert bis jetzt
meine Sicht auf die Dinge ist und ich
habe in vielen Ländern gelebt die
meisten Menschen mögen ihre Regierungen
nicht egal woher sie kommen
unsere Klienten tätigen ein Lifestyle
Investment sie investieren in ihren
Lebensstil hier in Kapstadt Südafrika
und der ist sehr hoch
auch wirtschaftlich ist Südafrika mit
Russland verbunden für seinen
Exportschlager Wein ist das Land
dringend auf russischen Kunstdünger
angewiesen mit den Winzern hätten wir
gerne über ihre Geschäfte gesprochen
doch wir bekommen nur Absagen vielleicht
auch weil der Export nach Russland seit
dem Krieg angestiegen ist
Geschäft vor Politik Russland ist nur
ein sehr kleiner Handelspartner
Südafrikas aber was macht Südafrika
eigentlich für die Russen interessant
eine Frage die mir Professor Irina
filatova beantworten soll die Russin hat
zehn Jahre an einer südafrikanischen
Universität gelehrt lebt jetzt in
Kapstadt
die Beziehungen zu Europa sind komplett
zerstört und die Beziehungen zu den USA
sind zerstört
worden Russland braucht also neue
Handelspartner und es braucht neue
Partner in dieser geopolitischen
Situation
Russland muss der Welt zeigen dass es
nicht isoliert ist und eine Menge
Freunde hat
es gebe auch eine andere Verbindung so
die 75-Jährige Afrika und Russland
fühlten sich vom westlichen Denken und
Wertesystemen kolonialisiert dabei haben
sie gerade dagegen gekämpft
russland hatte nicolonien in Afrika
erstens und zweitens hat es den Kampf um
Unabhängigkeit unterstützt es hat den
Kampf gegen Kolonialismus in der un-
unterstützt und praktisch hat es Waffen
Geld und politische Hilfe gegeben und
diese Erinnerung ist sehr wichtig
vielleicht also bestimmen gemeinsame
Erinnerungen das Verhältnis wir reisen
weiter nach Johannesburg in das
politische Herz Südafrikas und bekommen
überraschende Antworten
im Anflug aufs Paradies
[Musik]
warum Menschen nach Phuket Thailand in
den Urlaub fliegen muss man eigentlich
nicht fragen
aber was ausgerechnet so viele Russen
hierherbringt das schon Andrej
Dimitri geht das so einfach vom Krieg an
den Strand
10 Uhr die Aero flott was moskau ist
pünktlich gelandet 300 400 russische
Touristen an Bord eine von 8 Maschinen
die heute hier landen aus Russland und
Hannover verstehen dass die Russen kommt
sind die ungefähr 30 40 Grad mehr als zu
Hause
die dicken Jacken werden sie die
nächsten 14 Tage also nicht brauchen
aber Geld das brauchen sie thailändische
Bart
russische Kreditkarten sind gesperrt
Sanktionen und Rubel werden nicht
genommen was tun
in Russland tauschen wir Rubel zu Dollar
hier Dollar zu Bad
ein Visum gibt es on arrival also nach
Ankunft problemlos thailand gehört nicht
zu den Staaten die es den Russen
neuerdings schwerer machen keine Strafen
Restriktionen hier nicht der Krieg ist
weit weg scheint nicht so als wäre
Thailands Tourismus davon erschüttert
ich weiß nicht was ich erwartet habe
dass hier sieht normal aus fühlt es sich
auch so an wenn er jetzt nach Thailand
kommt wie empfängt man euch
kurz nachdem das alles anfing haben wir
geheiratet aber wir sind dann nicht auf
Hochzeitsreise gegangen weil wir uns
Sorgen gemacht haben
wir waren unsicher wie uns die Menschen
im Ausland begegnen
wir sind davon ausgegangen dass es
schwierig wird dass man uns Fragen
stellt auf die wir keine Antworten haben
das ist wenn wir auf Ukrainer treffen
ich weiß nicht das ist jetzt unsere
erste Reise seitdem es begann
zu fahren wenn dann Heimatland Krieg
führt ich bin es so leid wir sind alle
so müde es fühlt sich nicht merkwürdig
an wir sind müde wir brauchen eine Pause
wir brauchen Urlaub das Meer die Sonne
nichts anderes und wenn der Atomkrieg
kommt dann bin ich hier alles egal
zehn Flugstunden von Moskau eine andere
Welt
vielleicht fällt von den russischen
Gästen tatsächlich mehr ab als von
anderen Urlaubern
willkommen auf Phuket in der
Leichtigkeit des Seins
mit genauen Zahlen tun sich die
thailändischen Gastgeber schwer aber
gefühlt kommen 90% aller Gäste aus
Russland man hörte es und naja ab und zu
sieht man es vielleicht auch
[Musik]
Russland Reggae USA das Ranking von oben
nach unten passt schon irgendwie zur
Stimmung hier
Thailand hat harte Zeiten hinter sich
Pandemie wie überall aber für ein Land
das vom Tourismus lebt war nulltourismus
kaum zu ertragen
nivat will Eis verkaufen muss Eis
verkaufen endlich wieder
ich habe von dem Krieg gehört
aber ich will nicht mit ihnen darüber
sprechen das ist deren Sache
für uns ist es gut dass Thailand die
Russen weiterhin reinlässt
unsere Wirtschaft muss überleben
und wenig zu verdienen ist immer noch
besser als nichts
darauf verkauft hier Modeschmuck ist
Moral etwas das man sich leisten können
muss noch so eine Frage
erschreckend dieser Krieg früher hatten
wir so etwas aber heutzutage sollte es
doch keine Kriege mehr geben oder also
so sehe ich das jedenfalls
wir brauchen Touristen endlich kommen
wieder welche wir können sie nicht
abweisen wir können uns nicht erlauben
den Russen zu sagen ihr dürft nicht
kommen
Thailand braucht die Touristen
die Botschaft ist simpel und
nachvollziehbar auch drei Jahre Corona
haben Thailand gebeutelt jetzt sind die
Russen da
in so großer Zahl dass man sich
vielleicht fragen könnte ob das
Touristen aus anderen Nationen
beeindruckt oder sogar abschreckt doch
an dem Punkt ist Thailand noch nicht
aber macht Thailand gerade ein Geschäft
mit Beigeschmack oder sind das
vermurkste Vorstellungen moralische
Überheblichkeit Menschen machen Urlaub
fertig
tourismus-chef ist ein gut gelaunter
Mann beschäftigt ihn das alles überhaupt
wissen sie Krieg ist internationale
Politik und ich bin ein lokaler
Geschäftsmann für mich sind alle
willkommen in Phuket wenn ich
Außenminister wäre würde ich vielleicht
etwas anderes sagen
Thailands Regierung sagt sie bleiben
neutral heißt keine Verurteilung moskauz
keine Sanktionen sie zu aus als zahle
sich das aus
die Russen dominieren derzeit ganz klar
sie sind die größte Gruppe warum ist das
so
naja viele lieben Phuket ganz einfach
und wenn bei Ihnen zu Hause kalter
Winter herrscht finden Sie hier schönes
warmes Wetter
und ich denke es hat auch was mit der
Lage in Russland zu tun
das bringt sie dazu länger bei uns zu
bleiben
sie mieten ganze Häuser für einen immer
längeren Zeitraum und sie kommen
inzwischen mit der ganzen Familie
nicht mehr als alleinreisende der Kamera
sie bleiben länger oder sogar ganz ich
würde sagen ja sie wollen bleiben ich
höre aus unseren Krankenhäusern auf
Phuket das immer mehr russische Babys
hier zur Welt kommen wirklich ja im
Ernst
und findet ihr das gut sind das gute
Nachrichten
und wenn Leute dann länger bleiben
wollen dann tun sie das sowieso egal ob
mir das gefällt oder nicht man kann hier
jedenfalls klar ein Muster erkennen
ja es ist unübersehbar
Phukets Bauboom hängt nicht zuletzt an
russischer Nachfrage russischem Geld
das Luxussegment läuft besonders gut
draußen wird schon auf Russisch geworden
und drinnen sind russische Maklerinnen
gut im Geschäft aber sie sprechen nicht
gern darüber wir spüren Sorge als höre
und sehe Moskau alles zu Hause in
Russland sind Familie und Freunde
wir versuchen unser Glück an höherer
Stelle es ist die x-anfrage nach einem
Interview mit dem Priester der
russisch-orthodoxen Kirche von Pattaya
wie tickt die Gemeinde Russen die schon
länger fern der Heimat leben
die Absagen des Priesters sind recht
frostig alles weitere sollen wir beim
Moskauer Patriarchen klären
aber die Kirche ist offen steht ja da
bei der Vorbereitung des Gottesdienstes
hilft Dimitri mit und er spricht
ja ja Russen und Ukrainer beten hier
zusammen zusammen ja wir sind alle
Christen
ich kenne die Probleme die Politik die
ganze Situation ist hart für mich
das beschäftigt mich jeden Tag
aber das ist kein permanentes Problem
es braucht nur Zeit aber irgendwann wird
es wieder gut für uns alle
wir müssen geduldig sein und beten
für den Frieden
ja natürlich wir wollen Frieden
und Frieden wird wieder herrschen
in unserer Heimat
[Musik]
wir werden wieder zusammen leben so wie
früher
hier in der kleinen Kirche kommen Russen
und Ukrainer zurecht warum klappt das
bei den Staaten nicht
das mag für manche merkwürdig klingen
für mich nicht
wir sind Christen
uns geht es nicht um Heimatland im Sinne
von Boden
unsere Heimat ist der Himmel ist Gott
wie weit sind wir schon gekommen dass
mich so nachdenkliche Sätze überraschen
habe ich erwartet nur Putin Treue hard
zu treffen die gibt es hier sicher auch
aber es ist geradezu wohltuend dass das
Meinungsbild keinem Klischee folgen will
und dass wir miteinander sprechen können
[Musik]
hier aber ist das Gespräch erstmal
schwierig hier gibt es nur zwei Sprachen
die der Fäuste und Russisch beides nicht
das richtige für mich
Nikita 32 ist der einzige der Englisch
kann
der übersetzt für uns fragt ob wir
überhaupt hier drehen dürfen
kein Problem
die Boxschule in Pattaya brummt sie
liegt mitten in der Stadt und irgendwie
auch mitten im russischen Leben eine
Exklave
hier Boxen große kleine Touristen
Einwohner fast ausnahmslos Russen
Nikita studierter Rechtsanwalt aus
Moskau gekommen vor zwei Monaten
gekommen um zu bleiben
was ist mit deiner Familie ist die noch
in Russland
Terence
ja meine Eltern sind noch da
sind keine schlechten Menschen
aber es ist schwierig
was sie im russischen Fernsehen sehen
und auch im Internet das ist nur
Propaganda
das macht es schwierig
und diese Propaganda ist von höchster
Qualität
das muss man wissen
ja auch viele Leute in Europa
und viele glauben es
und in Russland sehen sie nur dieses
Zeug nichts anderes das ist verrückt
deshalb kann ich kaum mit ihnen reden
für dich gibt es keinen Weg zurück in
die Heimat nein moralisch betrachtet
geht das nicht kein Weg zurück
wenn ich zurückginge wäre ich nicht mehr
ich selbst das ist der entscheidende
Punkt
und wenn du in Russland wärst müsstest
du vielleicht auch kämpfen in diesem
Krieg dann hätten sie dich eingezogen
ja das ist doch
ich weiß dass das Militär schon vor
meiner Wohnung stand
um 5 Uhr morgens haben sie mit ihrem
Stiefeln gegen die Tür getreten
er lebt schon seit vielen Jahren ein
Pattaya äußerlich ein Krieger aus dem
Bilderbuch aber man soll ja nicht nach
dem Äußeren gehen
können
wenn jemand Sorge um seine Familie hat
um sein Leben und wenn er kein Soldat
sein will mit Waffen nichts zu tun haben
will dann soll er auch nicht in den
Krieg ziehen müssen
ich höre so viele vernünftige friedliche
Dinge hier bei euch ist das nicht ein
Beispiel dafür dass die Dinge besser
laufen können
Menschen sterben und keiner weiß wofür
ist
ja lass uns hoffen danke André
Russen in Thailand
freundlich empfangen warum auch nicht
das ist das Geschäft
sie kommen als Urlauber die eine kurze
Auszeit brauchen 14 Tage Sonne oder als
Dauergäste auf der Flucht vor Krieg
Militär dem Regime
alles gute Gründe so oder so
wir sind 400 Kilometer südlich von
Peking
außer dass diese Stadt für chinesische
Verhältnisse relativ klein ist weiß ich
noch nicht viel darüber
[Musik]
stolz zeigen uns
Joshua ihr neues Auto
es ist für das Paar noch ein bisschen
ungewohnt
wir kennen es bisher nur von ihren
tiktok Videos jetzt dürfen wir mitfahren
kommt sie die Marke ist eine Ikone
Chinas
rote Flagge so heißt die Marke ihre
massigen Limousinen sind in China vor
allem als Staatskarossen bekannt
ausländische Gäste werden in einem
solchen Wagen durch pekingsstraßen
kutschiert und natürlich Staatschef
schienenping
zusammen mit ihren mehr als 1,2
Millionen Followern haben Shogo und
Joshua auch viele andere Autos
angeschaut
den hier testen wir
und sich schließlich für Iris
entschieden weil es günstiger ist und
chinesisch
[Musik]
ist eine Marke die einen Platz im Herzen
vieler unserer Fans hat sie steht für
China
die beiden haben sich in Russland
kennengelernt dort ein paar Jahre
gemeinsam gelebt geheiratet seit knapp
einem Jahr sind sie in China und gerade
zu Besuch in der Heimatstadt des
28-Jährigen
Russland ist meine Heimat und China ist
meine zweite Heimat wir wollen
langfristig in China bleiben und hier
etwas aufbauen in China Kinder kriegen
auf dem Markt testen Sie wie die
zuckerrohrstangen schmecken
ihre Follower sind immer dabei
mit ihren tiktok Videos wollen Sie Geld
verdienen sie planen zukünftig in
online-livestreams Schmuck zu vermarkten
häufig zeigen sie in ihren Videos
einfach Ihren Alltag
früher haben sie auch über politische
Themen gesprochen zum Beispiel über die
Freundschaft zwischen China und Russland
über den Krieg in der Ukraine haben sie
kein Video gemacht
wir versuchen inzwischen politische
Themen und offizielle Inhalte soweit wie
möglich zu vermeiden wir sprechen jetzt
mehr über das Leben und machen
Unterhaltung
diese Videos würden auch am meisten
angeschaut den Krieg sieht jauge als
Chance für sein Geschäft er arbeitet für
Chinesen die in Russland Großhändler
sind hilft ihnen bei der Beschaffung von
Produkten wie Handytaschen oder
Ladekabeln
die Sanktionen des Westens helfen ihm
viele amerikanische und europäische
Marken dürfen nicht mehr in Russland
verkauft werden die brauchen aber die
Produkte was machen Sie sie kaufen die
Produkte aus China
die beiden nehmen uns mit zu ihrem
Cousin
er ist Pelzhändler
Fuchs Hase Nerz ich habe noch nie so
viel Pelz in einem Raum gesehen bis zu
90% seiner Verkäufe gehen nach Russland
in Moskau gibt es diese Bar mit was und
dafür möchte jeder einen Pelz haben oder
um zu heiraten da muss man auch einen
Pelz haben
20 Mitarbeitende hat er die Fabrik in
der die Pelze aufbereitet werden ist ein
Stockwerk höher der Krieg habe sein
Geschäft nicht sehr verändert
das viel größere Problem sei die
corona-pandemie
zu Beginn von Corona gab es viel weniger
Flüge die waren konnten nicht
transportiert werden und über Land
dauerte es viel länger
wenn der Transport wieder läuft macht er
sich um sein Geschäft keine Gedanken
mehr
zurück in Peking verabreden wir uns zu
einem Interview
denn eine wirkliche Antwort auf die
Frage auf welcher Seite china steht wenn
es um Russlands Krieg in der Ukraine
geht haben wir noch nicht
china steht in erster Linie auf Chinas
Seite das Land ist ein sehr egoistischer
Riese
China weiß genau wo die roten Linien des
Westens verlaufen
nur wenige Tage vor Kriegsbeginn war
Vladimir Putin gefeierter Gast in Peking
in der streng kontrollierten Blase der
Olympischen Winterspiele die viele
andere politische Gäste boykottierten
die Wirtschaftsbeziehungen der beiden
Länder sind seitdem deutlich enger laut
china hat der Handel 2022 einen neuen
Rekord erreicht plus 30% im Vergleich
zum Vorjahr
Russland ist inzwischen Chinas größter
Öllieferant
[Musik]
es ist eine Folge des Kriegs die
Partnerschaft wird zunehmend
asymmetrisch
immer mehr in der dominierenden Position
hat mehr Druckmittel und wird zum
Seniorpartner in den Beziehungen zu
Russland
offiziell verbindet die beiden
Präsidenten eine Freundschaft die vor
Jahren schon mit Kaviar gefeiert wurde
dass sie so eng ist wie vor den Kameras
inszeniert daran gibt es Zweifel für
hier reicht sie wohl genau so weit wie
sie ihm nutzt er will seinem Land den
Zugang zu Russlands Öl und Gas sichern
investiert in Pipelines und liefert was
Russland braucht
China wird zum Hauptlieferanten von
hochentwickelten technologiegütern für
Russland
ich gebe Ihnen mal ein markantes
Beispiel
der russische Automarkt besteht jetzt
aus 14 Marken aus drei russischen und
elf chinesischen
alle anderen also Mercedes Volkswagen
und BMW sind verschwunden
[Musik]
vor die der Westen mit seinen Sanktionen
hinterlässt das wollen wir uns anschauen
jemanden treffen der mit Autoteilen
handelt und das in seinem Alltag spürt
wir folgen dem Tipp der
pekingerschuhverkäuferin Anja und planen
eine Reise in die Hafenstadt Nienburg
Brasilien ist so groß wie Europa unsere
Reise ins Herz der Agrarindustrie dauert
fast einen ganzen Tag wir fliegen in den
Bundesstaat Mato Grosso
wörtlich dichtes Gestrüpp
doch von Büschen und Bäumen sieht man
hier nicht mehr allzu viel
Moto grosso ist die Korn oder besser
sojakammer Brasiliens einer der größten
Produzenten ist aus Waldo pascaloto auf
mehr als 100.000 Hektar baut er Soja und
Mais an
einen Tag lang begleiten wir ihn um zu
erfahren wie Brasiliens
Großgrundbesitzer auf den Krieg und den
Rest der Welt blicken
das ist eine Sojapflanze das ist die
beste Quelle für pflanzliches Eiweiß auf
der Welt und wir sind stolz dass hier in
mathegrosso produzieren zu können und in
die Welt zu exportieren
das ist wie Gold für euch
das ist unser Gold und wir sind sehr
stolz darauf
und es ist auch sehr wichtig für die
brasilianische Wirtschaft oder das ist
sehr wichtig für die brasilianische
Wirtschaft
Brasilien ist von Gott gesegnet
Brasilien hat gutes Wetter guten Boden
und fähige Leute um zu produzieren
Großproduzenten wie aus Valdo brauchen
viel Energie und Dünger zwei Faktoren
die unmittelbar mit dem Krieg auf der
anderen Seite der Welt zu tun haben
wie wirkt sich der ukraine-krieg auf sie
aus
der einen Seite hat der Krieg uns
Nachteile gebracht weil Düngemittel und
Diesel teurer werden der Preis hat sich
verdoppelt und das hat Auswirkungen auf
alle Bereiche der Landwirtschaft
auf der anderen Seite aber gibt es auch
Vorteile weil die Lebensmittelpreise
gestiegen sind die Ukraine ist ja jetzt
vom Markt verschwunden sie war ein
exzellenter Player und hat zum Beispiel
viel Weizen auf den Markt gebracht auch
so ja
wie sollte die brasilianische Regierung
reagieren
wir wollen dass wir neutral bleiben denn
wir wollen Geschäfte machen mit der
Ukraine mit Russland mit China und mit
der EU wir produzieren Lebensmittel
Lebensmittel sind keine Waffen jeder
muss Zugang dazu haben jeder muss essen
es gibt also überhaupt kein Grund und in
einen Krieg einzumischen der nicht der
unsere ist
Neutralität ist gut fürs Geschäft so
würden das auch die anderen
agrarunternehmer sehen sagt Oswaldo und
das war bisher auch die Position der
brasilianischen Regierung
hier wird das Soja geerntet da hinten am
Horizont sieht man das egal sollte die
brasilianische Regierung ihre
neutralitätsposition aufgeben was wären
dann Ihrer Meinung nach die größten
Risiken für Sie
es könnte ein Embargo Russlands geben
dass uns dann keine Düngemittel mehr
verkaufen würde ganz schnell würden die
Preise für Dünger noch weiter steigen
und das würde unsere Arbeit erschweren
und Lebensmittel würden auf der ganzen
Welt teurer werden
es sei die heilige Pflicht Brasiliens
die Welt zu ernähren sagt Oswaldo immer
wieder
erst Reich selbstbewusst hat mehrere
Flugzeuge und doch gibt es eine Sache
die ihm Angst macht dass ihm der Dünger
ausgehen könnte
Dünger ist die Achillesferse der
brasilianischen Agrarindustrie nach wie
vor sind Sie hier auf importer aus
Russland angewiesen bei Ausbruch des
Krieges hat Oswaldo noch einmal extra
viel eingekauft in seiner Halle Lagern
Phosphat Kalium und Chlorid vieles kommt
direkt aus Russland
Russland finanziert seinen Krieg unter
anderem damit
ja sie finanzieren einen Krieg damit sie
haben das Rohmaterial und sie
exportieren das in die ganze Welt und
Brasilien ist einer der wichtigsten
Käufer aber wir können nichts anpflanzen
wenn wir das nicht haben
damit helfen sie den Krieg zu
finanzieren haben sie da kein schlechtes
Gewissen
ich denke nicht an den Krieg ich denke
daran Lebensmittel zu produzieren das
wäre doch schlimm wenn wir aufhören
würden zu produzieren nur um Russland zu
schaden
der Pragmatismus regiert nicht nur auf
den Feldern Brasiliens sondern auch in
der Hauptstadt Brasilia gleicher Abstand
zu allen großen Mächten ist seit
Jahrzehnten das oberste Gebot im
brasilianischen Außenministerium
ein Kurs den selbstex-präsident
bolzenario beizubehalten versuchte als
er zu Bestürzung der westlichen
Alliierten noch kurz vor dem russischen
Überfall Präsident Putin besuchte
und auch der neue Präsident Lula scheint
diese Politik vorzuführen im Wahlkampf
sorgt er für Aufregung als er in einem
Interview der Ukraine die gleiche Schuld
am Krieg zu spricht wie Russland das hat
er inzwischen korrigiert aber die
Distanz bleibt warum die Antwort darauf
suchen wir in Sao Paulo der größten
Stadt Südamerikas und dem eigentlichen
Machtzentrum Brasiliens
wir sind verabredet mit Oliver Stünkel
Deutsch brasilianischer Professor für
internationale Politik und ein Kenner
der brasilianischen Diplomatie
letztendlich ist das Ziel
brasilianischer Politik eine eigene
Manövrierfähigkeit aufrecht zu erhalten
genau es geht darum die strategische
Unabhängigkeit von den USA zu erhalten
und nach brasilianische Auffassung sind
dazu die Beziehungen zu Russland China
und Europa sehr wichtig
die anderen Mächte als Gegengewicht zu
den USA also von der Gesellschaft wird
dieser Kurs mitgetragen auch weil viele
Menschen in Brasilien und Lateinamerika
den USA Misstrauen
zusammenfassen auch in der
brasilianischen Gesellschaft gibt es
einen ausgeprägten Anti-Amerikanismus
dies hat auch mit der langen Geschichte
der amerikanischen Einmischung in
Lateinamerika zu tun es gibt da einen
Konsens auf der linken und auf der
rechten es gibt hier eine
nationalistische linke bei der Vladimir
Putin sehr beliebt ist weil sie ihn als
großen Gegenspieler der Vereinigten
Staaten ansieht und auf der rechten ist
der beliebt weil sie ihn als den
traditionellen Mann ansieht in Russland
gibt es schließlich in Anführungszeichen
nur zwei Geschlechter und vor allem den
konservativen Mann der seine
traditionelle Kultur beschützt
diese Haltung hat womöglich auch
Bundeskanzler Scholz unterschätzt als er
Präsident Lula vor dem Hintergrund des
Ukraine Krieges um munitionslieferungen
bat und eine für Beobachter wenig
überraschende Abfuhr erhielt
brasilien ist ein Land des Friedens und
deshalb wollen wir nicht am Krieg
teilnehmen auch nicht in indirekter Form
[Musik]
Neutralität geht vor selbst bei einem
brutalen Angriffskrieg mitten in Europa
kann sich quasi den Leisten dieser
Verletzung internationaler
Geflogenheiten weiterhin diese Politik
und diese Haltung vorzufinden im Moment
ist die brasilianische Interpretation
folgende wir sind beim Thema
Umweltschutz und Klimawandel so wichtig
dass wir genug Spielraum haben um in der
Ukraine Frage in gewisser Weise mit den
Vereinigten Staaten und mit Europa nicht
übereinzustimmen
Mainz je mehr wir also als ein
unverzichtbarer Akteur im Kampf gegen
die Abholzung angesehen werden desto
mehr Spielraum haben wir unsere neutrale
Position gegenüber der Ukraine zu
verteidigen ähm
Brasilien setzt also auf einen
klassischen diplomatischen Kuhhandel
Neutralität im Krieg dafür voller
Einsatz beim Schutz des Regenwaldes erst
ein Schritt zurück und dann einer vor
Brasiliens ganz eigener Tanz auf der
Bühne der Weltpolitik
[Musik]
die russisch-orthodoxe Kirche am
Stadtrand von Johannesburg gut 100
Mitglieder hat die Gemeinde St Sergius
von radonisch
[Musik]
wir sind zum Gottesdienst willkommen
aber die Erlaubnis mussten wir vorher
aus Russland einholen
Pater Dani lugovoj dient der Gemeinde
seit 13 Jahren als Rektor die Messe ist
ein Stück Heimat fern der Heimat
natürlich lässt sich der Krieg in Europa
nicht ausblenden und er belastet auch
die Menschen hier in Johannesburg in St
Sergius beten Russen und Ukraine
gemeinsam als orthodoxe in einer
Gemeinde
wenn die Menschen mit ihren Sorgen
kommen mit ihren Problemen mit ihrem
Schmerz mit ihrem Tränen bieten wir an
gemeinsam zu beten
sie Gebete können Gedanken sorgen und
Gefühle besänftigen
warum kommen Menschen in die Kirche
um Frieden zu bekommen Hoffnung und der
Lösung
die Antwort eines Geistlichen ich hake
noch einmal nach sei der Krieg nicht
eine besondere Herausforderung
wenn Menschen sich über schwierige
Zeiten beschweren und wenn sie sich mit
der Geschichte der Welt beschäftigen gab
es kein Jahr ohne Probleme auf der Erde
ich muss no one
ist hier kein Platz für den Krieg
[Musik]
Katharina Riva lebt seit Jahren in
Südafrika geboren aber wurde sie in der
Ukraine
nun wir sind alle Menschen
es ist schwierig manchmal aber in der
Kirche sprechen wir nicht darüber ich
bin für Russland ich bin aus der Ukraine
das würden wir nicht tun
ja es gibt etwas Höheres als unsere
menschlichen Themen
[Musik]
wie kann es sein dass Südafrika das Land
des Freiheitskämpfers Nelson Mandela
sich jetzt er an der Seite Russlands
sieht das frage ich mich immer wieder
auf unserer Reise
Mandela und seine Partei einc die für
Gleichheit und Demokratie eintraten
und doch liegt ein Grund genau hier
Termin kann uns das erklären selten
werden wir so herzlich empfangen
[Musik]
seit 47 Jahren ist Tami Mitglied im einc
als junger Mann wurde er als Kämpfer
ausgebildet in Moskau denn die ehemalige
Sowjetunion hat den Kampf gegen die
Apartheid immer finanziell und
militärisch unterstützt
auch wenn es jetzt Russland ist und auch
wenn es jetzt diese Implosion gibt
betrachten wir die Russen immer noch als
die die uns geholfen haben
und die an unserer Seite standen in den
schwierigsten Zeiten als wir gegen die
Apartheid kämpften
und das können wir nicht einfach
ignorieren oder vergessen
sagt der 69-Jährige aber so widerspreche
ich niemand habe Russland angegriffen wo
gegen also zu verteidigen
no no no no
nein der Irak hat die USA nicht
angegriffen hat er nicht
aber die Amerikaner sind in den Irak
einmarschiert und haben ihn zurück in
die Steinzeit gebombt
die USA nicht angegriffen aber sie sind
in den Irak gegangen nach Libyen was zum
Tod Gaddafis geführt hat
kann man das Vergleichen frage ich mich
die USA wollten den Irak ja nicht
annektieren wir müssen weiter schade ich
hätte gerne länger mit Tami gesprochen
es ist bereichernd nicht alles aus der
westlichen Perspektive zu sehen
Russland weiß diese Haltung zu nutzen
erst vor wenigen Wochen war es Sergej
lavrov in Pretoria mit breiten Lächeln
und offenen Armen begrüßte der russische
Außenminister seine Amtskollegin lavros
charmoffensive dient vor allem der von
Russland gewünschten Reformen des
UN-Sicherheitsrates
wir unterstützen zusätzliche Sitze für
Entwicklungsländer sehr stark wenn die
Unterrepräsentation Afrikas Asiens und
Lateinamerikas ist das aktuelle
Grundproblem des Rates
mehr Afrika bei der UN könnte Russlands
Interessen dienen und Südafrikas
Außenministerin legte gleich nach das
Land lasse sich nichts vom Besten
vorschreiben
ich denke einfach dass es wichtig ist
dass wir alle Länder all souveräne
starten betrachten und nicht damit
aufhören wenn es gerade passt
wenn sich dann etwas ändert dann sollen
wir uns auf eine Seite schlagen
und wenn sich wieder etwas ändert auf
eine andere nein nein nein wir lassen
nicht zu dass diese Art von Spaltung von
und Südafrikanern verlangt wird
ich frage mich wie das die junge
Generation sieht die die nach dem Ende
der Apartheid geboren wurde und jetzt in
einer modernen und weltoffenen Stadt wie
Johannesburg lebt
bist
das jetzt auch wissen
mit einem Stipendium in Moskau studiert
seine Familie klassische Mittelschicht
hat lange gezögert mit uns zu sprechen
russland hat Neo viele Möglichkeiten
gegeben und Putin so sagt der sei doch
ein starker Präsident
als Person ist der sehr charismatisch
die Fotos die man von ihm sieht auf
einem Pferd mit nacktem Oberkörper das
ist Unterhaltung für mich es ist lustig
das zu sehen ich erinnere mich dass ich
Fotos von ihm gesehen habe wie er im Eis
geschwommen ist er ist charismatisch er
ist ein männlicher Mann
26-Jährige will einmal Diplomat werden
doch solange es noch nicht so weit ist
spricht der offen aus was viele
Afrikaner nicht nur die Südafrikas
denken
ehrlich zu sein Ukraine das ist in
Europa da sagt jeder wow wow was
passiert da aber der Krieg der gerade im
Kongo und Ruanda Tod der größte Krieg
darüber spricht niemand
auch das ist wahr
Afrikas Kriege und Probleme sind weit
entfernt von uns unsere Aufmerksamkeit
meist woanders Südafrika aber
emanzipiert sich und will als Partner
der mächtigen ernst genommen werden
drehreisen sind in China immer Reisen
ins Ungewisse
häufig werden Treffen in letzter Minute
abgesagt weil Interviewpartner von Staat
Sicherheit oder Polizei unter Druck
gesetzt werden
wir sind auf dem Weg nach Nienburg im
Osten Chinas ich bin gespannt darauf den
riesigen Hafen in echt zu sehen
mehr als 1,2 Milliarden Tonnen Fracht
sollen hier im vergangenen Jahr
umgeschlagen worden sein
wir sind mit Heiko und Marc verabredet
warum highbor uns alleine begrüßt
erzählt er uns später
der 45-Jährige handelt mit Autozubehör
und Metallwaren verkauft hauptsächlich
nach Russland seit mehr als zehn Jahren
das Geschäft läuft gerade sehr gut weil
wegen der Sanktionen des Westens viele
europäische Produkte fehlen
eigentlich ist der Markt gesättigt aber
wenn zum Beispiel Deutschland nicht mehr
verkauft gibt es eine Lücke Produkte aus
China können diese Lücke füllen
mit seinen MitarbeiterInnen machen er
erklärt es uns an einem Beispiel dass
die Deutschen doch kennen müssten wie er
meint
bei LKWs hatten zum Beispiel Bands oder
man ein Monopol in Russland
chinesische Hersteller hatten keine
Chance
jetzt hat Europa seine Position
aufgegeben sie verkaufen nicht mehr
aber der Bedarf ist noch da deswegen
haben chinesische Hersteller die Chance
in den russischen Markt zu kommen
mit Russland handelt drei bohren nicht
erst seit dem Krieg in der Ukraine
[Musik]
er stammt aus Chinas nördlichster
Provinz seine Heimatstadt ist nur 100
Kilometer von Russland entfernt
während meines Studiums war russisch die
erste Fremdsprache weil wir so nah an
der Grenze sind
wir fragen nach heibos Geschäftspartner
dem Russen Markt
und reibo haben sich im Studium
kennengelernt arbeiten seitdem zusammen
doch Max Platz ist leer eigentlich lebt
er in China aber wegen der geschlossenen
Grenzen während der corona-pandemie
konnte er nach einem Heimaturlaub nicht
zurückkommen
seit drei Jahren war er nicht mehr da
aber jetzt hat er endlich ein Visum
auf dem Weg zum Hafen denke ich zurück
an das Interview dass ich im Büro
geführt habe
china hat den Angriffskrieg Russlands
bislang nicht verurteilt doch das Land
kennt die roten Linien des Westens
es liefert zumindest offiziell kein
Kriegsmaterial an die eine oder andere
Seite es verstößt auch nicht gegen die
Sanktionen tut aber alles was noch
erlaubt ist und das ist ziemlich viel
der Krieg verändert die globale Ordnung
der Krieg beschleunigt russlandslos
Lösung vom Westen und seine Suche nach
alternativen Märkten und
technologiequellen und da ist China die
wichtigste Tür an die Wladimir Putin
klopfen kann damit hat China enorme
Einflussmöglichkeiten
nimmt uns mit in die Fabrik seines
Zulieferers
hier produzieren sie Hydraulikzylinder
für Maschinen die in der Landwirtschaft
und im Straßenbau eingesetzt werden
ja das geht alles nach Russland weil ihr
eure Sachen ja nicht mehr nach Russland
verkauft
ich finde das ist ein großer Verlust für
Europa
eigentlich sind die Deutschen Produkte
bei Russen sehr beliebt die chinesischen
Industrieprodukte hatten selten eine
Chance in Russland
aber jetzt wo sich Deutschland
zurückgezogen hat ich finde das ist ein
großer Verlust für Europa
privat würden sie schon über den Krieg
diskutieren auch im Netz der Schuldige
ist aus ihrer Sicht ganz klar die USA
sie hätten die Eskalation angezettelt
aber beim Geschäft und bei den 30
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern würde
der Krieg keine Rolle spielen sie wollen
dass ihr Staat sich um die Wirtschaft
kümmert nicht um die Politik anderer
Länder
als Unternehmer mischen wir uns nicht in
die Politik ein egal ob es um Russland
oder andere Länder
wir produzieren für den Alltag der Leute
wir gehen auf Ihre Bedürfnisse ein
ob in Russland oder in Europa die Leute
brauchen ja Dinge zum Leben
bloß nichts Politisches sagen das hören
wir auf unserer Reise immer wieder die
Unternehmer erzählen uns wie sehr sie
deutsche Produkte bewundern und können
nicht verstehen warum Deutschland mit
den Sanktionen gegen Russland freiwillig
auf Handel verzichtet es sind
vorsichtige Antworten mehr kriegen wir
nicht dafür sorgt die kontrollmacht des
chinesischen Staates sie bestimmt nicht
nur unsere Interviews sondern auch die
Freundschaft zu Russland die reicht
genauso weit wie sich China nutzt
[Musik]